joining us now author this book is been
on the New York Times list for an
eternity it's week numbered what nine or
ten number one bestseller on freedom of
the press the great one Mark Levine it
also the number one show on Fox on
Sunday night's life liberty love in I
had to talk this man into doing radio
that is a fact I made him do it he
didn't want to he was reluctant and
resistant great one what I love about
you is your brain more than anything
else and you are a great constitutional
scholar I worried about a republic after
what I saw today more than they have at
any point and I have been worried for a
while you know let me do a little
summation here as far as robert muller
goes I'm up to my nights with robert
muller no he was in no condition to
testify but on the other hand he was in
no condition to be a special counsel and
he should not have accepted the job and
rod rosen stein should never have
offered him the job the victim here is
not Mulliner the victim here is the
President of the United States and all
the other people who were around him I
want people to keep something in mind
about this 448 page report it is a
prosecutor's brief it was their best
shot there's no reply report by the
president that was permitted there's no
contrary witnesses no contrary documents
no contrary evidence no cross
examinations no challenges of any type
so this is a really soviet-style process
we're going through and I want to thank
the Democrats because they really
revealed themselves as the clowns that
they truly are they've impeached
themselves today and forever more if the
Democrats were truly interested mr.
Schiff which you said over and over
again in overwhelming Russian
involvement in a large campaign then why
the hell didn't should call Barack Obama
and Joe Biden to testify why the hell
didn't should call clapper and Brennan
and Lynch and Comey and Hillary Clinton
they're in charge of our government
they're the ones who allow the Russians
to have overwhelming influence in our
campaign and they kept their mouth shut
because they thought Hillary would win
and they didn't want to taint their
election
where's Barack Obama today's on some
ship in the Caribbean I suppose we
hillarie clear any of them now that's
that no I want to talk about obstruction
of justice
these Liberal Democrats who ran this
operation are such incompetent boobs
they cited three criminal obstruction
statutes that don't apply now that
people have studied this moreover what
document exactly did the president with
hole none what what witness that the
president prevent from testifying not
one one investigator a prosecutor that
the president fire not one what
resources did the president withhold not
one no conspiracy no obstruction now
let's talk a little bit more about
obstruction I mentioned this will be 45
seconds go ahead sir well it's too late
then side Muller's purview
everything's outside mullahs prayer of
you outside Hillary Clinton the DNC
fusion GPS Christopher steel Russia's
role in the still dossier the fights
applications McCabe's links trolls leaks
commis leaks
McCabe's coup attempt outside of the
purview Rosenstein conflict of interest
FBI placing spies in the Trump campaign
Obama administration's and unmasking of
American citizens the Obama
administration's failure to stop the
Russians all outside the purview but man
affords taxes
oh we never heard the end of it all
right I'm done brother mark
there were only a couple of us that put
our neck out in the beginning on this
you were one of them thank you great one
Mark Levin Sunday night number one show
book number one everything is number one